last night the united states brought the
world's number one
terrorist leader to justice
abu bakar al-baghdadi
is dead he was the founder and leader of
isis
the most ruthless and violent terror
organization anywhere in the world
the united states has been searching
for baghdadi for many years
capturing or killing baghdadi has been
the top
national security priority of my
administration
u.s special operations forces executed
a dangerous and daring nighttime raid
in northwestern syria and accomplished
their mission in grand style
the u.s personnel were incredible
i got to watch much of it
no personnel were lost
in the operation while a large number of
baghdadis fighters and companions
were killed with him he died after
running into a dead-end tunnel
whimpering and crying and screaming all
the way
the compound had been cleared by this
time
with people either surrendering or being
shot
and killed 11 young children were
moved out of the house and are uninjured
the only ones remaining
were baghdadi in the tunnel
and he had dragged three of his young
children with him
they were led to certain death he
reached the end of the tunnel
as our dogs chased him down
he ignited his vest killing himself
and the three children his body
was mutilated by the blast the tunnel
had caved in on it in addition
but test results gave certain
immediate and totally positive
identification it was him
the thug who tried so hard to intimidate
others spent his last
moments in utter fear in total panic and
dread
terrified of the american forces bearing
down on him we were in the compound for
approximately two hours
and after the mission was accomplished
we took highly sensitive material and
information
from the raid much having to do with
isis
origins future plans
things that we very much want
baghdadi's demise demonstrates america's
relentless pursuit of terrorist leaders
and our commitment to the enduring
and total defeat of isis and other
terrorist organizations
our reach is very long as you know last
month we announced that we
recently killed hamza bin laden
the very violent son of osama bin laden
who was saying very bad things about
people
about our country about the world
he was the heir apparent to al qaeda
terrorists who oppress and murder
innocent people
should never sleep soundly
knowing that we will completely destroy
them
these savage monsters will not escape
their fate
and they will not escape the final
judgment of god
baghdadi has been on the run for many
years
long before i took office
but in my direction as
commander-in-chief of the united states
we obliterated his caliphate 100 percent
in march of this year today's events are
another reminder that we will continue
to pursue
the remaining isis terrorists
to their brutal end that also goes for
other terrorist organizations
they are likewise in our sights
baghdadi and the losers who worked for
him
and losers they are they had no idea
what they were getting into
in some cases they were very frightened
puppies
in other cases they were hardcore
killers
but they killed many many people
their murder of innocent americans james
foley
stephen shotloff peter kasich
and kayla mueller were especially
heinous the shocking publicized murder
of jordanian pilot
a wonderful young man spoke to the king
of jordan they all knew him they all
loved
he was burned alive in a cage for all to
see
on the execution of christians
in libya and egypt as well as the
genocidal mass murder of
yeshides rank isis among the most
depraved organizations
the history of our world
the forced religious conversions
the orange suits prior to
so many beheadings all of which were
openly displayed for the world to see
this was all that abu
bakr al-baghdadi
this is what he wanted this is what he
was proud of
he was a sick and depraved
man and now he's gone
baghdadi was vicious
and violent and he died in a vicious and
violent way as a coward running
and crying this raid was
impeccable and could only have taken
place with the
acknowledgement and help of certain
other nations and people
i want to thank the nations of russia
turkey
syria and iraq and i also want to thank
the syrian kurds for certain support
they were able to give us
this was a very very dangerous
mission thank you as well to the great
intelligence professionals
who helped make this very successful
journey
possible i want to thank the soldiers
and sailors
airmen and marines involved in last
night's
operation you are the very best there is
anywhere in the world no matter where
you go there is nobody
even close i want to thank
general mark milley and our joint chiefs
of staff
and i also want to thank our
professionals
who work in other agencies of the united
states government
and were critical to the mission's
unbelievable success
last night was a great night for the
united states
and for the world a brutal killer
one who has caused so much hardship and
death
has violently been eliminated
he will never again harm another
innocent man
woman or child he died like a dog
he died like a coward the world
is now a much safer place
god bless america thank you